what do we do with all these books none
okay what's up everybody happy monday no
we're feeling on a Wednesday but it's
Monday Oh Monday comes out tomorrow so
tomorrow when this goes like the book
would come up tomorrow we're filming is
wednesday night at ten o'clock something
like that you can see this [ __ ] you can
see the shape of your muscles yeah we're
looking at nitez muscles name is proud
of her month will give us a flexing it
was a full arm flirty wow look at that
let me see do it again hello I need to
touch the flex oh look at that that's
solid work there so we have a ton of
books here nice to figure out what to do
with the publisher first sent me this
this is the very first copy you guys
have seen it in some of the videos it's
the soft cover version that there is no
other soft cover version we don't have a
soft cover version this is the the demo
uncorrected proof for limited
distribution this has a ton of spelling
errors and anyways just like to get it
out into people's hands this was the
original first draft that I got this is
the this was the advance hardcover copy
that I got that's been in my on my
display when you see me but with the
computer which I was super excited by
still proud of this this is the first
one guys I need to put a mark in here or
something gotta make sure it doesn't get
lost with all that oh well hello look at
this who's that look at that yeah look
at that that's exciting okay so all of
these boxes full of books arrived how
many boxes 17 well that's two boxes at
the bottom what's he so like 18 18 boxes
of books I don't know how many oh
there's 12 and each 18 times 12 is a big
number 96
I think that's hundred 96 wait no no I
didn't run shaking too long yeah well i
feeI 886 ya did it calculator mm-hmm
well anyone trust me and so I don't know
what to do with these books I'm on the
fence let me I could use some feedback
guys I'm on the fence with this so yeah
hundred 96 okay it is right good job
okay okay Lena's the smarty pants and
strong a strong fine prints are you
sitting just like that so that the
mushroom show is that we doing so you
can see you hello Nina seem like like
this and then I'm just relaxing here
sitting on the trampoline and the up ok
I'm back on topic I really help guys any
help with this on the one hand I want
the book to get into as many hands as
possible and I want to be consumed and
distributed and I've even thought as far
as even me personally buying a whole
bunch of copies to give out even looking
at my students at Toronto dance salsa or
you know loyal website viewers in buying
a couple thousand copies and giving them
away to people because I want the
message to spread that's one side of me
the other side of me feels like when you
give people stuff for free they don't
value it and they don't do anything with
it and it bothers me because the last
thing I want is for people to get this
thing and not use it right there's so
much love of this and it's so that the
impact is so a huge potentially if you
read it and actually apply it to your
life that I don't want people to just
not value it and not read it and not do
the work so this is my struggle you know
that's why I have 196 yeah we've 196
books I don't need 196 books I could
sell the books but it's not really the
business I want to be in it's not really
the model I could give them away but I
wanted sure they're there I don't know i
don't i don't feel like i want to give
them away why don't you do something
like that way and the read
are they doing a Merry Christmas like
one person have hope whoever needs to
help them most for the to have a merry
Christmas to give him money yeah but you
can't vote yourself what was that person
that person has to read it though so I'm
gonna throw it to you guys I don't think
I'm going to be able to charge Nina 41
bucks if she's going to take one to read
on the subway so that's one hundred and
ninety five bucks left I thought that
myself that's true you did but yours are
coming later so he's gonna take one with
a signature and a lovely note Wow and
there's gonna be a hundred five left I
want to know what I should do with them
I think if I'm gonna give them away then
stand then how do I ensure that they get
red cuz just saying I'm going to read it
it's not enough because people talk
people talk all day long and then they
don't take action you know how many
people said I'm gonna move to Canada
when you know Donald Trump wins the
election and then nobody cut like people
talk people talk and they don't do
anything and don't do that with my book
I'm gonna be pissed off if you talk and
don't do anything about my book so I
don't want to give to those people so
how do we how do we differentiate
between the people who are gonna do
something I need ideas guys believe
nation turn out leave it in the comments
below I need ideas okay let's let's open
one of these but I want to take a video
I mean I had to be in the mena insisted
on being in the video so it is is to be
in the video let's open up the box and
we'll see you go neither go do in the
box we open a box use those muscles use
your Nina strength that you're showing
up oh it's amazing look at that guys
look at that huh yeah I like it okay
[ __ ] gonna pick one yeah I know it's
okay okay okay Nina's I need a sharpie
we have a sharpie I'll get you a nice to
pen and no not a pet a sharpie now it's
Chevy Chevy is like the the marker the
black marker so you so suffice thanks
would I feel like I need to walk around
with a sharpie you need to walk around
with a sharpie so that we can do this I
don't have a sharpie I have a pink
highlighter huh near against the thing
is this one this is a nice tank in a
paper just scrap it on the fridge okay
thanks Chris what did you call it scrubs
scrap scrap scrap is how you say it oh
look at that works for me please okay
Nina's neat oh that's a sharpie what
does wanted this no that's a thin
sharpie though that's a good one that's
gonna go through i'm pretty sure you
supposed to sign books with a sharpie
but Nina likes doing things differently
so it's part of why he left her by the
way that and that she's strong and it's
good at math it makes cooking videos
what's the next cooking video I mean
people want 250 videos but I want the
food no you sign on the first page well
if you tell where do you want to sign it
you tell me outside of where be you want
I don't know hey what do you want to
thank you you're gonna just pinch to 183
yeah right here you want to date it
what's the actual day today November
30th this is the first i didn't even
sign my own copy november 30th dear me
thank you so much for your let's just
take an effort okay binky then writing
in and on a wobbly box okay okay thank
you for your that she helps your ongoing
love and support none
of
this
word
be possible
without
your
hashtag
Carrie
sir one word is caring love for ever for
ever this for the right thing so kind of
miss apart no I did where we're start
we're forever yes yeah that's right
don't I'm freaking out but forever and
the heart with a balloon what do you
think the balloon in a balloon let me
feel it a balloon yeah you're the only
one that gets the heart in the balloon
okay that's the google lunar look at
that balloon that's an amazing believing
okay Evan look at that guys guys this is
the very first inscription of the book
look look ok now look isn't that a great
balloon oh I'm going to the wrong way
come on look at that balloon people
gonna want their own okay you got the
first okay love you MA thank you okay
I'm gonna move on some questions before
that let me know I need I need your
input leave in the comments that's one
down 195 to go what are we doing let me
know okay you answer questions with me I
don't know how to answer questions what
do mean you learn the question is your
name nina know what give me the book bag
can't to find it more real Nina's is
dear Nina okay I'm gonna answer some
questions so first question replicate 70
bless you Evan thank you your excitement
is so infectious I love it i pre-ordered
your book in the UK so a study group
format would really enhance my
experience also someone who is super
keen to write a book of his own
capturing your book publishing journey
is mega valuable could all the relevant
videos be bundled up in a book writing
tool box you so deserve your success for
all the value you're giving so many
people in the world don't ever leave us
my friend cool I mean so much luv there
thank you for that replicate 70 as long
as I'm enjoying having fun and feeling
the
I'm not going to leave because this
stuff fuels me in terms of putting all
the all the content into a toolbox maybe
I think if you go back on all of the
videos this is video number 77 so
there's a lot of content around how to
write a book how to market a book how to
promote a book there's a lot of content
in there that if you were just starting
up and trying to get a deal with a big
publisher and understand how that works
I would check it out I might condense it
I don't know I don't know it's not on my
list of priorities if I had to write
another book on something or make a new
product it wouldn't be around how to
write a book I've got other things
stewing in here I got them some things
doing so we'll see I don't know I might
come back to it but thank you for the
love i really appreciate the question
and the support from amazon in the UK
next up I'm grade this I bear after
hearing your schedule I just wonder how
you avoid getting distracted and you
spend too much time on the gym so you
have to correct elsewhere what's your
method on that I think having a schedule
prevents me from getting distracted I
think knowing what I'm doing on
different days knowing what I'm doing
when I wake up having that you know I
gotta be here by this time gets me
hustling and prevents me from getting
distracted I think when you don't know
what to do that's when you get
distracted when you when you have as
much time in the world you get
distracted what I know that it's video
day and I have three hours to make all
my videos for the week that I'm hustling
and grind and then getting it out and
I'm not super distracted the other thing
i find it really helps me is i will
message myself if i get an idea i will
send an email to myself and then usually
on fridays will go through all my emails
and kind of sort out what i'm going to
do with those so that i would be the
type of person if i get an idea it'll
stick with me and I'll be so worried
about forgetting it then I'll get
distracted and stop doing something else
or I won't give my hundred percent to it
because I'm thinking about this idea so
just email myself that's it then I look
through it on Friday but again most of
that happens on the weekend most of it
happens in leisure time also that
happens when
I come out of the shower or something
doesn't really have like what I'm
focused mode like right now all I'm
caring about is making this video for
you guys I'm not this track they're
thinking about other stuff or what I
have to do tomorrow I'm just focused on
what I'm doing so yeah I don't know I
think having the schedule keeps me from
getting distracted the bee song
pre-order is done in Germany bonuses
arrived thank you and your team
especially Sandra Sandra has been
awesome Sandra is sending out all the
bonuses so if you buy a copy of the book
and then email us you receipt you get a
whole bunch of free bonuses and
depending how many you buy you get more
bonuses stuff as well and so yeah
Sandra's been amazing this definitely
would not have been possible for that
Sandra's help and so I'm glad you're
feeling the love that came back from
that side too next up Bertha knee this
was an awesome video do you want us to
forward you our receipt or can you reply
with your email again hashtag BTW a21
email in your receipt if you go to the
website that has the the book ever come
with a calm / one word on there as an
email there's a link I think if you
click on the sale and then there's an
email link click on that it'll email it
to it won't come to me it'll come to
Sandra a special email address and then
you'll get your your bonuses and I'll
make my special video thank you video
most likely for you so yes please email
in your seat it also helps us keep track
which we can use that data to tell the
book retailers in different states where
we're getting some interest until
they'll make sure the stock it in those
stores so that's helpful relevant to so
yes please email in your seats abdullahi
hi having what about the weekends so
this reference to my last video talking
about scheduling on the weekends it's
usually family stuff saturday is usually
our activity day so we might go hiking
we might check out a new restaurant we
might go to a show we might go to a
movie it's usually something different
to do in the city Nina is a big fan of
different food trying out different food
places in the outdoors and so I try to
factor that in as much as possible try
two different restaurant new kind of
food some new place its opening or some
new dish that's out or getting out of
the city and going off
some hugs we had some amazing fall hikes
how do we do we do three to two full
hikes we did two hikes and it's great to
see the leaves changing colors and so
you should Saturday something fun to do
because we're working basically all week
between my work doing this and my
business and then tryna then salsa at
nina's involved with TDS as well it's a
pretty crazy week which we enjoy but
it's nice having a day to just be
together and have fun sunday ends up
being our family day / Aaron's day Nina
does some tds stuff as well on Sunday
and so it's it's it's cleaning up the
condo or going to home depot and doing
some improvements or going to Nina's
parents house and having breakfast or
lunch just family and errands days
typically are sunday i'll be on email on
breaks and stuff you know if we're
standing in line at home depot or
whatever but there's no scheduled work I
don't have anything planned in on
saturday or sunday that I have to check
a video or respond the email or you know
get back to my team members its kind of
off limits which helps me also come up
with ideas for what I want to do gives
me a little bit of freedom and
flexibility in that lets me email myself
those ideas I can follow through up
during the week next up David the
superhero my post on an Evan video today
is an amazing day I love that David the
energy is awesome and yeah I remember
wasn't going so well at the start my
thoughts back then were how is it
possible that this guy is getting this
few views but you just kept going and
here we are eight almost nine years
later you're the living embodiment of
your word thanks David it really
appreciate that you know coming up on
half a million subscribers on the
channel it's been an amazing amazing
journey I I didn't really started almost
nine years ago if you ask me I probably
would have said maybe six or seven but
it's crazy it's been nine years yeah and
the early videos were not getting a lot
of use and not like if I had one comment
I was over the moon excited and happy
and it's just grinding it out
and doing more videos and improving the
process and getting better in you know
Here I am ten o'clock on a Wednesday
night making a video to give me another
first book and to chat with you guys and
so it's it's again it's the torture that
you enjoy that other people would see is
torture but you just you loved the work
you gotta love the process and in the
past nine years have been fun and i look
forward to keep doing it until I stop
getting interested in it and then I'll
go through something else but for now
you guys got me next up chef Bruno
heaven just want to throw a big up for
your new book and a huge thank you for
most your videos I'm not commenting ever
will appreciate you commented on this
one chef Bruno I know I shouldn't gives
motivation and I also like to receive
comments on what I do help people quit
smoking in China every day and every
early evening one hour of your channels
with top 10 rules how others persist my
girlfriend and I are real grateful for
what you do is it helps us and enlighten
us and how to stay on track and keep
developing our businesses so just one
more time big up and keep up this
amazing thing you have it's great and we
love it that's awesome man i really
appreciate that really feeling the love
there i'm curious to know what what kind
of Chef you are and the food you're
making mean I sure would enjoy talking
and chilling and checking out your
YouTube channel and you get that going
one thing I find really interesting is
people who watch the videos together
especially a couple's or business
partners watching it together and just
talking about it afterwards like what
did you get from that or what did you
learn from that what was your favorite
point and it always leads to more
insight and discussion into what that
other person is all about what they
found most interesting and then it
really enriches the conversation and
brings a lot more insight into your life
and your business and so if you have the
business partner if you have another
entrepreneurial friend who you think
might value the videos i would i would
suggest just trying at least once having
a viewing party or just sitting down and
watching one of the top 10 videos
together in pausing it when you want to
talk about something
and then just just having a conversation
but afterwards i'm curious i think it
would be really really enriching and i
would challenge you guys to to give that
a shot and if anybody does and you do it
together fill a quick video of you guys
doing it together and what you learn
from the video what the video was and
what you learn film that send it to me I
want to see it I want to see it you
might even get featured on the channel
I'm just saying that might happen next
up Jill Stella whatever Party you decide
to have I want to be there Congrats Evan
on your book release coming soon thanks
Jill yeah maybe I'm still on the fence I
don't know what I'm on the fence attend
not to do things and when I want to get
excited about something I just I just go
out and do it so i don't know maybe
maybe maybe i'll just hit get hit with
inspiration a lot of trouble people want
to just do something and will show up
and get it going i don't know i'm gonna
sit on it Jill I don't know I love them
I love the support though thank you so
much really means a lot Diallo hey I see
Steve Jobs behind you great thanks man
yeah you know I believe the environment
is important where you work is important
to people around is important what's on
your walls is important you know you you
have the ability wherever you work to do
something even if you're at a job
somewhere you can have a little picture
somewhere i did a video that we can link
up that talked about the people on my
wall and why the ones you can see here
is his jobs this is Howard Schultz who
started starbucks and that's my parents
and me when I was seven years old so
yeah I think it's important to have an
environment that that builds you up next
up legacy artist big homie Evan putting
in that work I love that brow I've never
been called big homie Evan so that's
that's a first I'm feeling it thanks man
I really appreciate it I feel like we
might need a big homie Evan theme song
or something I could get down to that
have it on kind of repeat before making
videos give it a good beat get to work
on that legacy artist and all you are
the fans out there well I want a
soundtrack dimitar hey there Evan
appreciate your videos are always so
inspired and helpful i do however have
problems with managing my time come to
think of it as spend way too much time
on the brakes and i don't know how to
schedule my learning process plus
there's a lot of things that I can't
learn
my own I need help and there's no one to
help me can you give me advice on that
please one inch in the second part first
you can learn a lot of stuff on your own
man like the resources out there insane
compared to what they used to be if you
want to learn about entrepreneurship I'm
giving you free content multiple times
per day of some of the best and
brightest people in the world that can
help you do your thing so that's one
resource but there's lots of people are
doing their own thing too if you want to
learn about marketing as marketing
channels you want to learn with sales
and sales channels you want to learn
about cooking call up chef Bruno you
know or there's other cooking channels
you can check out to whatever still you
want to learn it's never been easier I
mean it used to be go to a library this
books on this whatever you want to learn
it's in a book now this video is on it
to like it you don't have an excuse for
scene there's no one to teach you is it
there are people online the resources
that you have are insane so just start
learning it just get past a mental block
to say you don't I know the people i
don't have entrepreneurs in my life
guiding me and giving me direction and
and i'm asking their feedback on the
people that I look up to other people
that I'm making videos on I consider
them my mentors and my teacher is it
every time I do a top 10 video or
believe life or any of those series I
learned something from that I apply to
my life in my business and so you could
do exactly the same thing the first part
was about spending too much time on
breaks I think you just need to do
something that you like if you love the
work then you don't spend too much time
on breaks right like if I'm talking to
an entrepreneur I when I went to go make
the audio version of this book I didn't
want to break I didn't want a food break
I didn't want a bathroom break I didn't
want to break at all we broke only when
the the crew you know we're at their
limits and like I really need to go to
the bathroom ok ok ok let's break I
didn't want to break you know when you
love what you're doing you don't want to
break and so I think you just need to
find more meaningful work that really
inspires you then you won't need to
break you won't spend too much time on
your breaks I mean yes at some point you
need to break okay but you're not going
to spend way too long a break because
you can't wait to get back to the work
right you want to get back to the
project
next up three colors Zed Zed Zed zzzzzz
Canadians you say that you have two
businesses your YouTube channel in
Toronto the insults my question is how
do you make money from your Evan
character youtube channel since it's a
business thanks my Evan chemical
business is not just a YouTube channel
it's my website half my team is just on
the website I started on the website and
then i added you tube to the mix oh my
website has been around a lot longer
that's advertising that's that's brand
deals that's partnerships on the YouTube
side it's basically the same mix as
advertising its brand deals it's a
moving into product right selling the
book getting speaking gigs that kind of
work like when you when you have
attention that people want to work with
you and so if you're starting a YouTube
channel and you're trying to get a
business model around it some of it will
be advertising but then you need to
think about how you can monetize the
attention better that you're having
whether that's like I don't do a lot of
product sales but you could do you could
do t-shirts you could do pins and
buttons or EV guides I could have made a
lot more money selling this myself I'm
not using a publisher right back to the
the point of the top like I could I
could take these two of your books and
just sell them myself whether I give
them for free or do some kind of
promotion with them like it's not a ton
of money in my pocket and every ongoing
sale that happens I don't even know how
to make the percentage is tiny right
like authors you don't make a ton of
money off of a book it's not the game
but it's the attention that you get that
then you can funnel ideal into other
things thus ma a 91 family I don't get
the question I love my family though the
be thong what the two books cut down the
one is there a way to get the 60,000
words as a bonus ebook for the people
who pre-order like me and all the other
people by the way in bold I ask because
it's too bad to know the 60,000 words
from your heart and soul haven't made
into the book maybe you can discuss some
content in the hangouts they has an
interesting one
I don't know what I'm going to do with
the extra thirty thousand words 30,000
words no 60,000 words 60 90 120 thousand
total yeah so 60 thousand words yeah I
don't know I don't know my publisher
wants me to my agent wants me to hold
off and save it as another book and I'm
like I already have two other books in
mind and it's not this I don't want to
release this as a book this isn't a book
like it's it's a it's an extra for this
book but it's not its own book and she's
she's not happy with me that she wants
to release it as another because it's
basically already written has to be
proof read and you know couple minor
things we fixed that but it's basically
already written I don't know I might
it's one of the things too like the book
launch party I might do something with
it um maybe address it on the hangouts I
don't know I'm excited with the hangout
series to then go deeper and an answer
the questions so if we do a chapter per
week to then be able to give really rich
feedback to you if you've read the book
because I want to make sure people are
reading the book right like I want you
to read the book and do the exercises
and if we go through chapter one and
then you guys have questions about
chapter one then I'd love to be able to
address those for you and then maybe
what will will seep into some extra
content I don't know it's interesting
it's interesting and I'm gonna keep that
one of mine IWC io pre-ordered on
audible thank you so much love i really
appreciate it make sure again you email
in your seat I want to make sure you're
getting the bonuses and we can keep
track to black stop Daniel Messer do you
create most of the videos yourself with
a full time job I find it hard to create
a blog post daily and edit record any
suggestions so at this point I am NOT
work I'm not doing everything myself I
have a team well we can go through them
i have i have three editors i have a
researcher I have someone who man my
just a lot my comments I have a someone
else with a strategy in the direction
but that's part time and I have a camera
man who works who is also part time so
let's let's throw those two in the one
so six people am I missing anybody maybe
some people help on the audio and south
so like six seven people plus me
the videos right that's only on the
YouTube side there's another six people
seven people on the website side doing
other stuff yeah I mean when I started
there was just me dude I was doing
everything everything I was making one
video a week but I was doing everything
I was doing the research for I was doing
the camera work for and I was in front
of the camera I was doing all the
editing the editing was what killed me
the other name was it took a ton of time
and I didn't enjoy it so I was really
slow at it and then the first person
that I hired on the YouTube side once i
started make a little bit of money was a
part-time editor that evolved into a
full-time editor in that editor allowed
me to go for making a video of a week to
a video a day that so it's like seven
times right there's a lot more content
and then as a I'd built my team we could
go to two videos a day and then three
videos a day and sometimes four or five
videos a day just depending on the
schedule yeah and it started off with
you know if i look at my editing team
Christina does a ton of the work on the
editing hi Christina and then as we
started building up more contests she's
like this is a lot I'm struggling to
meet all of our deadlines and get
everything out and she said hey my
husband Sam is also video editor maybe
he could do some of the work and he
started off his part-time and then we
filled up his schedule he became
full-time and so you know he's working
under christina and now as we expand it
even more we need they're both crunched
for time and so their friend is also
video editor who works for us now and so
it's a lot of work it's a lot of work
doing this stuff i mean and there's me i
have to sit there record 20 videos every
week right it's a ton of work but going
back to the early stages yeah you just
gotta you gotta put a new schedule the
time to make it happen you know monday
afternoon i'm going to record my video
every week and I block you know you can
block off two hours to make a video or
an hour I don't know how good you are in
front of a camera how long it takes you
you know block off two hours to make
your video and then Thursday afternoon
you're going to block off three hours to
do the editing for whatever it is like
however long it takes you to do it
schedule it in
that it gets done the big rocks first
because otherwise you're not going to do
it it's always going to be on this one
day list and you're always going to feel
like you're behind on it and you never
have enough time to do it it's not going
to happen until you schedule it in and
make it a pro in your calendar that's it
guys are going to end it there how long
is this video we're getting up there on
time so I gotta get back to Nina we're
going to watch some arrow I think and
enjoy the rest of our night if you have
a question about my book which launches
tomorrow crazy if you have a question
about that my book writing process and
if you have any thoughts on what I
should do with those 195 extra books
please leave it down below and I can
review and answer your questions in next
week's video thank you guys so much for
the support it's really meant a lot to
me this this you know really wouldn't be
happening without all of you guys behind
and your encouragement and your
endorsement in your support just it's
overwhelming it's amazing I really
appreciate all of you so thank you I
believe in you guys I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is what you love I'll see you
soon